on this episode the legend that Joe
stops by everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 2 18 of
the ask gary vee show and if you're a
Jersey boy least cuz if you love music
you're as happy as I am right now
because I have a legend with me that Joe
my man won't you tell the vaynernation
for the one person who's watching this
and who knows where in the world that
doesn't know who you are once you spend
a minute to say hello to the
vaynernation how's it going my brothers
my name is Fat Joe originally from the
Bronx New York reside in Miami for the
last 14 years the weather are amazing in
Miami
regionally a member of the diggin in a
crate screw that's Lord Ferdinand
showbiz happy birthday lord finesse
showbiz nadar d-roc big al rest in peace
then the leading founder president of
terror squad that's uh
rest in peace Big Pun uh Remy ba DJ
Khaled the list goes on and on : je
whatever in Fat Joe listen I'm sure
everybody knows and if they don't that's
their mistake
tell me what's what's on your mind these
days a lot of people that are watching
right now entrepreneurs marketers
business people the kind of people you
would enjoy you know I was born in
Russia came up you know baseball cards
lemonade stand a lot of people watch us
hustling making things happen what's
going on in your business world what are
you excited about obviously Khaled had
this phenomenal situation last year with
snapchat you know obviously you've been
out and about well you know I'm
president of urban and a Latino division
of a company called market America shop
comm and we teach people how to be
entrepreneurs and teach them the
importance of residual income yes
working one time in your life and always
getting paid for it forever so I work
with my Latinos and my black people in
this business but the business been
around for
for years and Asians and white people
you know have made three and a half
billion dollars doing this business
right here so I'm teaching the Latinos
and the black people how to do this you
know we sell vitamins sell makeup
motives cosmetics shop I've been doing
that for the last two years as well as
I've always been doing my music you know
my my my main also is my music you know
I've been doing that since day one when
a music hater like like literally at the
wound like when you were three you were
like well I loved music since day one
but growing up in the Bronx you know uh
emulating my brother you know what I'm
saying looking out my window outside my
window is pretty much where hip-hop was
created you know and we had what they
used to call gems black block parties
right outside my window so me being four
or five years old I used to see them
come outside and bring the turntables
and I used to go out there and listen to
the music and I just fell in love with
hip-hop breakdancing and graffiti you
know I got into so much trouble writing
the fitti the trains so I got thrown out
of maybe six seven high junior high
schools writing graffiti is I mean um
and then I got into rapping and battle
rapping everybody and I always say I was
the original Eminem cuz you know I used
to battle a whole bunch of black kids
but I had blonde hair and green eyes and
I was kickin that gangster [ __ ] and it
was looking at me like I was [ __ ]
crazy every time and uh here we are
yep you know so actually my own now I'm
being selfish I'm sorry I'm just taking
full advantage what's what's the what's
your point of view on the current state
of hip-hop like what are you seeing out
there what are your thoughts on some
people that are coming up what people
listening up Jayco yep you know I'm a
huge ACO fan I love is uh freedom of
expression you know um push your tease
my favorite album whom I love Kanye
West's new album
I love music men and I and everything
got involved you know what I'm saying
like I love our era that I came out in
the 90s but I also think that the error
before ours LL Cool J public enemy Heavy
D cameras one was better than ours sure
all right yeah I grew up with it so you
know I feel like a lot of the legends
the people they've been through it like
yourself sometimes too often or quick to
downplay ten you know seven years ago
the south or new guys that come up like
do you feel like that there's too much
of that like people are trying to push
against it because it's not theirs yeah
I believe I believe I just believe a
deceive off I just believe there's a
will right either you either gotta go
over you know I know that or leaves you
behind and uh and I don't want to sound
like the grouchy old right in my day
yeah my day was like this in it so you
gotta just you know embrace to you you
know you ready answer some questions
absolutely India you ready to ask some
questions Andy did you think that you
would have a day in your career were you
gonna ask Fat Joe questions was this
something that you thought as a little
girl growing up in San Francisco well
yeah okay let's fire away Oh video
clayton's
all right hey Fat Joe welcome to the
show yeah question I have is you did
that song with a Shanti a while ago I
think it was called what's love how do
artists ever hook up and how did they
get to collaborate with each other like
is there somebody like producers brings
that or like agent or how does that
happen how do collabos happen I mean
taking away a lot of times with me when
I make music um I hear certain artists
on it and I reach out and I hope they
want to work with me and flat out you're
like you're like plant you got in your
head and you're like oh this would be
perfect so let's get that let's just say
cool & Dre uh we-well Scott Storch may
get it poppin and I immediately heard
Nelly on there yeah so we reached out
him : j made up the hook and i reached
out to nelly and I was like Nelly do you
want to do this hook over for me and he
said yes so we heard him on a song
so make it rain I wrote the hook to make
it rain and ice I heard little Wayne on
it because it was a south song and I was
like you're Wayne could you do this over
he did it so you hear a certain artist
that you want to collaborate with on the
songs and you hope they don't ever been
devastated when you really want it not
devastated but I've been chasing future
on this album and he's been acting real
Hollywood with me
you know like acting like he don't want
to do the song you know to be honest
with you but it ain't hard to get you
think yeah hard to get sometimes is like
that you know of course let me let me
play it in for everybody's watching same
thing in business a lot of people always
ask me how do you get an angel deals
when you invested with people when
you're doing these things it comes in
all forms sometimes it comes to you
sometimes you reach out but I love I'm
just curious how you were going to
answer it I look I think sometimes
people try to big up too much and they
have too much pride and they don't want
to reach out when you want something you
have to go out and grab it I love that
instead of you saying oh sometimes it
comes to me or this and that you said
look I hear somebody I want it I'll
reach out sometimes they say yes
sometimes they say no but way too many
people watching right now isn't you know
successful this man is in his onra you
know me how many of you are too proud to
reach out to do something with somebody
and you haven't made [ __ ] happen yet now
that's not that's not how it works
oh it's not that's not how it works I
think one thing and I'll use this moment
I've been wanting to say this to really
win you have to equally pull at ego and
humility what do you think what I've
done this what I've done on the new Fat
Joe and one of the new Fabio came huh
and you're maybe this year okay
and with let's just say all the way up
okay bye yep I've had like riffs and and
and not everything was so good between
me and jay-z in the past I reached out
to him be the bigger one yes and
collaborate it and we did the remix uh I
did not see I did not see eye to eye
with daddy yankee I got him on the
Spanish remix owe me a 50-cent uh made
piece
you know we perform together not too
long ago I leave you are you enjoying
I'm enjoying it because you late you
eliminate all the barriers that's right
you know what I'm saying all the enemies
and obviously both is having a January 1
thing for you no it wasn't a January one
it was just me I tried all the wars
right and then I just said to myself I
said you know what I'm gonna eliminate
all obstacles and I'm going to try to
say put all ego and pride aside and let
me just try the non ego route let me try
working with everybody and and and see
how this working so far we're platinum
on a single going to double platinum and
tours are opening up and every day can I
hear yeah yeah everything is ready and
some it's a mute this is a magical
miracle pill that seems to be working
yeah it happens I'm glad you went there
it's been a theme of mine over my whole
life but I've been weave with all the
[ __ ] that's going on in the world if you
if you can't go 1/2 glass full if you
can't be the person of change and drive
positivity and optimism I just think
it's a mistake India
Craig ass what do you think of people
like chance the rapper releasing a lot
of his music for free as a marketing
strategy we should change the rap people
like chance the rapper winning budget I
love chance the rapper hey what do you
think about people like chance and
others that are putting out a lot of
mixtapes
a lot of product for free as a marketing
play or whatever their strategy may be I
love it I think you keep the relevancy
and you keep the fans engage and I love
it I think it's I think it's a hustle it
shows that you dedicated to the art and
at the end of the day that the art
wasn't meant to be a materialism and
everything's a dollar it's it's about
giving back to your fans anyway I think
the one thing that a lot of you are
watching know is I don't have the $500
ebooks and the $7000 courses I do these
shows for free I pump out content at
scale for free thousands of you
email me every single month you should
charge for this this is better than a
[ __ ] I'm paying more for it plays into
that same thesis which is yes but that's
why so many more of you follow me you
get more luck of course it's either
you're running a marathon or you're
running a sprint figure out what you're
doing
India OTW Houston asks what is the most
important or best aspect of a live music
event or experience the most important
aspect is you I'm just getting the
people engaged you see I try to die
every time I'm on stage die die I go so
hard that you just might die I like that
I think I would I would love to die on
stage seriously right seriously and um
so what happens is good these days
you're probably less likely to do that
then back in the day you know more
likely you're looking good oh yeah I'm a
charm but I work out everything I can a
day you might have been able to pull
that off
you're looking good though now but what
happens is um
I've analyzed it so hard to where times
are hard and and everybody doesn't have
money like that and everybody doesn't
get money the same way and I've analyzed
it to where people buy tickets to go to
shows to wear every single dollar tells
a different story
so everybody who's in this audience had
to do a different thing work harder work
extra hours borrow some money sell
something that they really love to see
their favorite rapper do whatever so
every ticket tells a different story so
it's my obligation that if they went
through their you know to do all these
changes to see the me being their
favorite rapper that I have to give them
my all and I love that what's your thing
you know this isn't now me jumping in
what's your favorite what are some of
your favorite venues to perform in you
have a favorite venue or - whoa whoa saw
you at Citi Field well my favorite show
I've ever done in my life was last night
and last on your favorite show I've ever
done in my life
my best moment my best moment in my
career was last night well I worked
until 2:00 in the morning and I'm up
since 5:00 working so I missed I Anita I
need to hear to school so what happened
was um yesterday I did summer stage and
Crotona Park in the Bronx and it's the
park I grew up in it's like three blocks
away from my neighborhood my grandmother
grew up three blocks in that direction
I grew up three blocks in this direction
they've never seen no [ __ ] like this so
it's usually 500 people at that it was
literally 20,000 people there and 5,000
feet no I've seen everybody's mother
everybody I went to school we some
people haven't seen years it looked like
summer jam man it looked like summer jam
in the middle of the park I grew up and
I have a scar where I fell in the pool
where I have stitches my father sold I
seized and and beef patties in the
summer in this park like it was the it
was a coming home oh my god and almost
cried onstage and I'm too macho for that
you never performed there before it was
the craziest [ __ ] I ever seen in my life
so when I got onstage and it was
overwhelming when I looked out look like
Yankee Stadium and it was my whole
neighborhood and I was like oh [ __ ] and
so many years I've been fighting for the
Bronx and and and and talking about
y'all I'm from the Bronx and
representing the Bronson when I seen
that they all came out they were like
yeah bro that's nothing home you know
I'm saying it was it was the biggest
moment for me in my life
congratulations that's nice thank you it
is awesome
so Martin Morin hey guys what's up but
who do you really want to work before
you die keep up the good work
I'll go first I want to work with Vince
McMahon don't know yes sir and I'll tell
you why
WB yeah but we're old-school WWF go oh
yeah I'm Macho Man Randy Savage
Randy uh for me for me I love
storytelling and I love people that love
characters when you think what I get
excited about is Walt Disney Vince
McMahon people that create characters
and IP intellectual properties so for me
Vince is intriguing to me because I I
mean I'm an you know I'm 40 I grew up in
that era of the golden year of that
Hulkamania macho madness and so hoaxes
mommy yeah hope was in here the other
day it was a lot of fun so I was for me
it's pensive man you [ __ ] what was the
question again because he got me [ __ ]
up I would I was in your hours and
Gary's world right now
what was the question again the person I
want to work with before I die um I
don't know I think I would want to do a
movie with Will Smith something like
that you know uh whilst you know will
woody I mean you were around back then
it's like you know he or was he a little
earlier like I was earlier than me and I
meant well maybe once or twice but I
mean like if there's anybody I want to
make a movie with as well spill you
thought about doing collaborations on
cross genre music and you ever list
I mean record a country singer well
that's who I want to work with country
music really yes well I can I actually
this is Miam farm far as a fan like just
think about it I have a funny feeling
that you would do quite well in
collaborations in different genres it is
true and that's why I'm looking towards
right now country music I'm not just
predicting social media [ __ ] Andy I'm
pretty acoustic cause it's [ __ ] true
it's the trove I'm looking towards
country I don't know I don't know [ __ ]
about country but I [ __ ] love that
their fans are law you I love that their
fans are [ __ ] lawyer and I love their
like hip-hop they're just telling it
their own way hundred percent coming
from the ground up I [ __ ] love it you
imagine that G&T Swift that would be the
summer answer some people get beat up at
country [ __ ] - I see no Kenny Chesney
[ __ ] there's tons everywhere what do we
got one more that's it yeah that's true
ok ok just Joe where are you at with
social media social media at first I was
anti social media right by the way real
quick I want to I want to teach a lot of
people here because a lot of youngsters
what social media came up when I jumped
like oh six oh seven oh eight oh nine
when people were famous back then it was
just a small little thing and see yeah
it was a small plaque we were more like
private we didn't want people to know
our bill because the media was already
writing stuff they didn't want anyway so
like why do I need more of this they
didn't understand it then things of that
nature started very very late so with me
like put it like this I had a blackberry
last year
blackberry doesn't even have Instagram
and social media so what happened was
how was the presidential smart one must
are like it was very great like when I
finally got me a [ __ ] iPhone I was
like way too [ __ ] slow motion like
what are you just holding out on a
principle you made a lot of [ __ ] wait a
minute real quick you had a real you
made a lot of changes a lot of
technology yeah I know I'm watching I
know isn't it great [ __ ] phenomenal
you looked and I've been I've been di
love 2016 at night and I was and I was
uh and now I remind social media my own
Facebook yes with a my own you do an
Instagram ever fun what about snapchat -
when I love it all when Khalid started
blowing up in December November December
January was were you talking about it
did you see it like what well it came
from a real place what happened with
what happened with Alec was and I and
this could be breaking news to the world
hey I like breaking news what happened
with Khalid was Khalid was at a very low
point in his life yet I wouldn't come
out that didn't do too well he has some
very close friends they started to turn
their back on him and he found himself
in his home on the talking to the lion
and talking on the kayak and race talk
in it and he was just discovered this
snap thing so he just started talking
and being humble and talking to the
people and the next you know people
discovered what I discovered 10-15 years
before that he's the most amazing
[ __ ] on earth and now he turned
into Beatlemania it's insanity so that's
how we all you know America got to
discover the real dj khaled and it's
amazing because other than that you know
so in other words
you had to go to adversity right fall to
get up and he really got a oh [ __ ] he's
taking Arianna hug all the way he's all
the way up I mean I don't know what he
might be selling dog food next okay he's
selling ever done everybody wants him
milk his name is brought up in all three
of these floors every day with every
brand in the world incredible
unbelievable Joe you get to ask the
question a day every guest that comes on
gets to ask all these entrepreneurs
business people you know motivated
individuals any question hundreds of
answers on Facebook and YouTube any
question you want to know from the
masses my question is what are we going
to do about these police killing these
people in America and how can we change
it because my fans and my followers are
asking me this
and I'm not God I'm not Jesus Christ I
can't I don't have the answers right so
maybe you guys can give me the smartest
answers in the world because what are we
going to do because I feel like America
is going a hundred steps back you know
and is very it's like for all of us who
took a hundred steps forward and came
together as one big race and in this
room alone we have so much diversity and
we all look to each other as one big
happy family
there's a group of us out there that's
trying to erase that and split us up and
I'm tired of seeing men get killed you
know by people power tripping and
there's nothing I can do about it and
it's getting really really really really
scary out there and I love my country
yep and I don't have the answers well
great
team let's round up five or seven the
best ones to get it over to him as well
to make sure any season Joe this is real
honor for me have you ever shown Thank
You IRA should continue success you keep
asking questions we'll keep answering
them
you